Vous êtes 100 000 sur ma chaîne YouTube!
Plus 23 000..
Hein..
Parce que le temps que je fasse cette vidéo
en fait maintenant vous êtes 123 000
Je voulais la faire pour les 100 000 mais j'ai un peu raté le coche
voilà c'était pas prêt, et tout. Je voulais vous annoncer des choses.
Mais du coup ça me fait encore plus plaisir !
Et en plus YouTube m'a envoyé ce petit cadeau !
Voilà ! Ça c'est vous là !
C'est vous !
Donc c'est super sympa
Avec une petite lettre pour dire "bravo"
Je ne sais pas encore lequel des deux je vais accrocher !
En fait c'est con à dire,
mais c'est cool d'avoir un objet matériel qui symbolise ça.
Parce que sinon c'est quoi ?
C'est des chiffres, c'est des pages Web, c'est des fichiers
C'est important d'avoir de temps en temps un ancrage réel quoi
C'est comme quand on se voit dans la vraie vie, les conventions les choses comme ça : donc c'est cool.
En tout cas, voilà sincèrement, je voulais vous remercier d'être aussi nombreux
Ca me fait énormément plaisir
C'est même pas une question de "Ouais, je ne m'y attendais pas"
ou "je m'y attendais" non
C'est juste qu'en fait, ça fait plaisir quoi !
Il y a deux ans et demi j'ai lancé ce projet
j'étais tout seul, j'ai mis beaucoup d'efforts et de bonne volonté
Donc, ça fait plaisir de voir que j'ai réussi à rassembler des gens autour de ça
que ça intéresse des gens
qui ont possiblement appris des choses
ou en tout cas, j'espère, passé un bon moment
Et rien que ça c'est OUF !
Et quand je vous croise dans la rue
chaque fois c'est bienveillant
des fois j'ai des conversations intéressantes
C'est GÉNIAL !
Je voulais sincèrement vous remercier quoi
Mais je profite de cette vidéo pour vous dire quelques trucs
hyper importants
D'abord je lance une newsletter
C'est un mail que vous recevrez
une fois par semaine ou une fois par mois
au début ça risque d'être une fois par mois
le temps que je comprenne comment ça marche et que je me mette dedans
Et ce mail va récapituler plein de trucs intéressants qui se sont passés
des trucs intéressants, des news, des découvertes, des articles, des réflexions
PLEIN de trucs !
Pour ceux qui me suivent sur Facebook
d'ailleurs vous êtes bientôt 20 000 et ça tue !
Vous voyez exactement ce que je veux dire !
Par exemple cette semaine j'ai partagé une conférence Ted
(qui vous a d'ailleurs pas mal plu)
c'est ce genre de choses
Il suffit d'aller sur cyrusnorth.com
vous balancez votre adresse et voilà !
Evidemment, votre adresse, je ne la file à personne, on est d'accord
et vous pouvez vous désabonner en un clic
qui sera dans le mail
et si vous voulez vous pouvez vous réabonner derrière
Hyper easy !
Et ce sera aussi le moyen pour moi de vous annoncer des trucs importants
par rapport à mes projets, ou des nouveautés
Je le dis parce qu'on m'a posé la question sur Périscope
parce que je l'ai annoncé pour voir ce que les gens en penseraient
Évidemment c'est gratuit !
Pour vous en tout cas. Moi ça me coûte un peu,
Mais ça me fait plaisir vraiment !
Parce que c'est un projet qui m'intéresse
C'est vraiment un truc que je kifferais avoir dans ma boîte mail
Du coup bah... je le fais !
J'espère que ça va vous plaire !
Ensuite, YouTube a enfin annoncé les sous-titres collaboratifs en France !
donc ça défonce !
Vous pouvez contribuer à faire des sous-titres sur les vidéos
Ce qui est ouf c'est que je ne l'ai même pas encore annoncé, sur aucune plateforme
Et il y a déjà des gens qui ont fait des sous-titres !
Je crois que la vidéo sur Hegel est sous-titrée en français
ça défonce ! Merci beaucoup
Je vous en parle parce que je sais que vous êtes cultivés
et que parmi vous il y a plein de gens qui parlent plusieurs langues
et ce serait génial quoi !
Avant les autres langues, déjà, le français
pour nos amis malentendants, ça, ce serait top !
Alors nous en plus, Français, on n'est pas mal en philo
on a de bons philosophes avec nous
Ce serait pas mal de montrer aux Anglais et aux Allemands
qu'ils peuvent rentrer chez eux quoi
que le YouTube français, il est au-dessus du game en philo
ça serait pas mal
Je dis ça, je dis rien
Et de la même façon si on peut rendre ça accessible
aux Brésiliens, aux Chinois, aux Espagnols
ce serait dingue !
Pour sous-titrer une vidéo c'est très simple en fait
il suffit d'aller sur la vidéo que vous voulez
et sur la barre de lecture
il y a une petite roue dentée (c'est la roue des paramètres)
vous cliquez dessus, "sous-titres", "ajouter sous-titres"
Et c'est parti mon kiki !
Du coup si vous voulez sous-titrer une vidéo, vous pouvez y aller !
Et si jamais vous le faites
je pense que c'est mieux de commencer par les Coups de Phil
car c'est dans ces épisodes là qu'il y a le plus de connaissances
de connaissances brutes
donc c'est ce qui pourrait intéresser potentiellement plus
les étrangers et les Français malentendants
c'est plus utile en fait
Dernière chose : je lance un compte Tipee
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas :
vous voyez le financement participatif ?
c'est totalement l'inverse !
le financement participatif : tu finances un projet pour qu'il existe
par exemple Chroma
Là c'est l'inverse parce que le projet existe déjà !
c'est ma chaîne et c'est financé par moi
par exemple : mon matos...
... mes caméras... D'ailleurs je ne sais pas si vous avez vu
mais je l'ai un peu amélioré. Genre des fois il y a deux caméras
sur certains épisodes, les Pop-up par exemple
Je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu.
Bref ! Il y a aussi des prestataires
du graphisme pour des logos etc, certaines musiques
il y a aussi du développement informatique
ça c'est mon projet pour le coup
mais il y a du décor aussi, genre des choses comme ça
... micros... Enfin bref ! Pas mal de trucs
Qui du coup sont ma responsabilité
et c'est mon projet donc c'est normal que je le finance
et ça prend du temps, que je pourrais consacrer à des clients par exemple
sachant que du temps, il en reste pas beaucoup parce que j'ai un taf
Donc voilà, tout ça c'est mon projet.
et ça me permet de vous faire des vidéos gratos
qui je pense, j'espère, sont de qualité quoi
c'est le but
et avec Tipee je vous permets de soutenir tout ça
différemment que par un Like ou un Partage
ce qui est déjà un très très bon soutien, qu'on soit d'accord
Tipee c'est un système qui permet de soutenir financièrement un créateur
et c'est un système qu'on retrouve dans plein de pays du monde
et en France il y a déjà pas mal de créateurs qui sont dessus
depuis en plus pas mal de temps.
Du coup pour savoir si vous devez donner à un créateur
je peux reprendre les 3 questions de mon collègue Bruce (e-penser)
1) Est-ce que mon boulot justifie une rétribution ?
2) Est-ce que vous voulez soutenir ce créateur ?
3) Est-ce que vous pouvez vous le permettre (ce qui est hyper important)
Parce qu'il ne faut pas que ça vous fasse chier en fait
Il faut que ce soit par plaisir
C'est du volontariat pur
Et il n'y a aucune différence
(en tout cas pour moi) entre une personne qui donne et une qui ne donne pas
Il ne va rien se passer
C'est la même chose pour tout le monde
Donc en fait, ce projet-là, c'est mon projet,
c'est mon envie,
c'est mes décisions, mes coûts, mon temps
Mais si vous voulez maintenant, donner un coup de pouce
au lieu de donner un Coup de Phil, eh bien, vous pouvez
Si en plus, après, ça me permet de dégager du temps
pour m'y mettre encore plus
ce serait génial
Par contre je ne veux surtout pas que ça change notre relation !
C'est hyper important pour moi
c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment du volontariat
Et je ne vous l'ai pas annoncé avant,
car je ne voulais pas le faire alors que vous étiez 20 000
et vous le rappeler tous les quatre matins
J'ai préféré attendre que vous soyez plus nombreux
et vous l'annoncer d'un coup
et si je vous en reparle, ce ne sera pas tout de suite
l'idée c'est ça
Donc je vous ai tout dit : inscrivez-vous à la newsletter
c'est le second truc le plus important de cette vidéo
le premier c'est MERCI
Ensuite si vous voulez faire des sous-titres, allez-y
et checkez le Tipeee
et je vous envoie beaucoup de love
CIAO BABY !